there's just so much energy behind that  album  give me like your mind state when it  came to getting in the studio and laying  your vocals for that album and just  being around that environment at the  time wow well  you know uh at that time  we all had something to prove  uh not just to the world but to  ourselves  so everybody was in a show and improved  mindset  musically  for the producers  you know dr dre himself  daz stepping his game up produce records  like for all my [ __ ] and my [ __ ]  and  was one of the keys to ain't no fun  you know what i'm saying and uh  you know being around dr dre makes you  step your game up you got to show up or  shut and show out  or get out that was a death row  mentality so everybody was trying to  prove themselves